if you took a a ping pong ball and you
put it in a bag and for each year that
human civilization has existed uh say
going back 5 000 years uh the very first
cosmological models in the Bible in
ancient Egypt and Samaria and you wrote
on it what's your model of the universe
like is it Eternal is it cyclical is
there a turtle on top of a turtle is
there a uroburos eating its tail what is
it just just put it in there the
overwhelming number of ping pong balls
would have a static Eternal Universe
Einstein believed in it Newton believed
in it it's interesting the Bible does
not believe in it the Bible has a
creation event right there are Egyptian
myths that have a creation but most
models most people for all time believed
that the Universe was static and in fact
the name that we get static meaning it
exists has always existed and will
always exist as it is exactly right 100
right so uh and why do we know that well
we're sitting on this thing called the
planet I don't know if you know any
Greek my Greek's not that strong but
Planet means Wanderer well why do we
have a name it's like Jews we talk about
people that aren't Jewish we call them
goyam or we you know it just means
Nation it's not like a put down or
anything
um but that's interesting because like
we're only 0.2 percent of the population
of the world right so we're saying we
have a name for the night now like I
just call them people and like we're the
weird ones right but but anyway uh so we
have a name for these things that moved
they're called planets well why were
they special because they were the only
things that moved everything else is
static it looks like it's unchanging we
know the stars move a little bit but you
couldn't perceive them over human
lifetime but the five planets that they
could see back then after which our days
are named and so forth there's deep
inculcation of astronomy in our daily
lives we just take for granted but but
anyway
um those things move and so it was
natural to suspect as Newton did as
Einstein did that the Universe was
static and eternal uh and that prevailed
for an extremely long period the
preponderance of human history and so we
asked the question of what could
overthrow that well before I would say
the last decade it was impossible to
speculate any more than just purely
qualitatively but now with telescopes
and tools like that of my team uh that
my team and I are working on called the
Simon's Observatory and other competitor
teams we're looking potentially at a
relic just like these water molecules
reveal the fiery Fusion conditions that
were present in the first second after
the big bang we're able to go 30 orders
of magnitude farther back in time
and we will reveal the presence via what
are called gravitational waves those
gravitational waves would originate from
a Quantum a purely Quantum phase of the
universe's history called inflation okay
what does any of that mean okay so the
universe the question is did the
universe come from what's called The
Singularity or not was there a point of
infinite temperature infinite density
infinite energy from which all the
matter and energy that we're
experiencing today came from including
the molecules in here including every
cell in our body the matter of that so
forgive me I'm just trying to make it
simple enough that it is like me can
understand hopefully other people
watching can understand as well so the
idea of the Big Bang is you have this
matter that is
I'm I'm using very stupid language I'm
aware but it's super condensed
absolutely and then it explodes and
cools over time and that's how you get
the universe exactly so it's either that
yeah or or a static Universe there are
actually other or more than one other
alternative yeah it could be that there
was a preceding universe that had a big
bang in Reverse called a big crunch it
could be that there are multiple
universes that exist parallel to ours of
which we're just one that has properties
features and phenomena consistent with
the existence of cosmologists and
podcasts and people right so we want to
know is our universe an accident yeah is
it a fluctuation a fluke and using
technology for the first time we can
confirm that we could potentially reveal
that our universe did in fact begin not
only with the singularity with a point
of incomprehensible hellscape like
energy density pressure everything you
could imagine
but it would also reveal the presence of
what's called a Multiverse
just as Copernicus and Galileo showed
that the Earth is just a planet it's not
the center of the universe as people
have thought for thousands of years now
back to Aristotle and beyond that the
Universe was centered on the earth
because that was a natural place for it
to be no they disproved that they
conjectured in the case of Copernicus
and proved in the sense of Galileo and
eventually Isaac Newton no but there's
more than one planet there's more than
one star there's more than one Galaxy
there's more than one cluster there's
more than one supercluster of galaxies
why not more than one universe and in
fact can comatant with the singular
origin of the universe
comes the Multiverse so in other words
you almost cannot have a single
Singularity a big bang without having a
Multiverse they're almost wetted at the
hip so the stakes are very high because
that's very in you know it's very
incompatible with say biblical
narratives or it's incompatible with a
lot of philosophical uh speculation that
you could have parallel multiple
universes in fact they may not be even
distant from us just like they may be in
very closely related to us or they may
be us in the sense of what's called many
worlds Multiverse interpretation so the
stakes are very high it's the most
primitive thing this is why I'm so
interested this is why I do what I do
because to study where everything came
from where potentially as Stephen
Hawking said asking what came before the
Big Bang is meaningless as asking what's
north of the North Pole he may have been
wrong surprisingly uh he may have been
wrong no it would be very interesting I
asked I would say to ask God if God
exists to say what happened on the
Tuesday before the Big Bang that may
have an answer for the first time in
history by technology that my colleagues
who are far smarter than I am are
helping to build via What's called the
Simon's Observatory which is located
it's actually one one of the if not the
highest altitude construction project in
the world building a massive telescope
array
130 million dollar project funded
primarily by the Simons foundation in
Manhattan New York and this is to
unravel what caused the bang was there a
big banger or was it all a spontaneous
fluke and if it was a big bang are there
other universes parallel to ours in a
sense I think you know for me it's one
of the most exciting things to Grapple
with when are we going to find out well
if you join my webinar
uh so the the challenging thing is that
these things take time we're almost done
with construction we have colleagues
that are there right now in Chile this
is in the Atacama Desert 5200 meters
above sea level 17 000 feet above seal
as I said highest observatory in the
world the highest construction project
in the world higher than you know the
base station permanent base station
Mount Everest very challenging
conditions uh very low oxygen extreme
ultraviolet damage from the Sun but it
does make you know it's compared to
going to Mars it's like a cakewalk so
Elon is welcome to spend some time there
are active volcanoes next door to us
um and uh it's a very uh inhospitable
place we're delayed by the pandemic a
year and a half two three years which
costs money because you can't just say
well I know you're going to get your PhD
working in the Keating laboratory come
back in two and a half years when things
are you know no we couldn't do that so
we kept it going cost more money and
luckily been able to see it through so
yes we're about to get what's called
First Light when we'll get the first
astronomical data later this calendar
year 2023 and then we should have
results a year later but what I always
caution people is that we won't be able
to say
definitively we won't be able to say yes
there was definitely a singularity you
could however say that there was no
singularity in other words you can in
science you have to be careful most
people think it's like math you can
prove one plus one equals two you can
prove you guys know this that uh you
know sign is is opposite over hypotenuse
right trigonometry isn't that right you
guys know anything okay you can prove
those things yeah I know it goes back to
Euclid uh right so you can prove those
men you can't prove something in physics
you can't prove that you know the Big
Bang but you can rule out the other
Alternatives and so therefore you can
falsify things about alternative models
so by discovering the pattern that we're
searching for we would not prove the
singularity but we'd falsify the
Alternatives including some purported by
Nobel Laureate and friend of mine and
your Countryman sir Roger Penrose who
has a model that's a cyclical universe
that Cycles into and out of existence so
I always say my job is to not prove
theories is to kill theories prove them
wrong and I think that's where it's nice
to kind of marry the theoretical with
the experimental and hopefully we
unveiled new knowledge about the origin
of the only story that had no precedent
perhaps
foreign